tout va bien a commenté
d'or le monde ne tient qu'à un fil
bientôt le virus breizh nous aura tous
anéantis
ce bâtiment a été conçu pour vous
protéger
c'est votre remparts
oh ils l'emmènent
qui nous cache quelque chose qui nous
ont menti sur son identité thomas tu as
vu quoi ne s'est pas évadé ses week-ends
ça fait partie de leur plan
je n'ai qu'une seule question à poser de
quel côté tu es
et vite coma
dire du labyrinthe c'est une chose sur
vivre sur la terre brûlée en étudiant
on a quelque chose en nous que week end
veut il ne faut pas se faire prendre
vous n'êtes pas obligé de venir je sais
qu'on peut atteindre notre but
personne n'a quitté la terre brûlait
depuis longtemps
allons-y
tous ces gamins sacrifiés je veux pas
finir quand même
bonjour thomas vous me connaissez
donc nos pâtes sont morts pour qu'on
puisse arriver jusque là
on n'a pas le droit d'abandonner
week end a fait tellement de victimes
ils ne s'arrêteront pas
c'est moi qui stoppé
j'ai pas envie de savoir comment on en
est arrivé là
tu n'est plus très loin de la vérité
ado ce soir